even though Immigration and Customs
Enforcement or ice has been ramping up
arrests and deportations houses of
worship are one of the few places they
still won't raid religious leaders of
different faiths have banded together to
treat our immigration laws like a joke
and I don't believe in jokes so I sat
down with a Jew a Christian and a Muslim
and boy are my arms tired the new
sanctuary movement is a collection of
churches providing hospitality who are
welcoming those who are threatened with
deportation or detention or some other
form of removal from the country
Christians right always a race to be the
martyr there are 40 organizations like
this across the country saying that
what's happening what our government is
doing we believe is illogical immoral
and unamerican
you three disagree on so much like which
gods are gods
why do you agree on this it is an
obligation even if you have only small
amount of food you have to share even
Jesus himself was escaping torture and
all of these and he's seeking refuge
talking about Jesus Christian I think we
all feel is part of what we call the
Abrahamic tradition that welcoming
strangers is one of the most powerful
things and that exists at the core of
our tradition as it does at the core of
the Jewish tradition and as it does at
the core of the Islamic faith as well
sure Jesus welcomed lepers and
prostitutes but I don't remember
anything about him hanging out with
Pakistanis checkmate